[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-From studio 6B
in Rockefeller Center
in the heart of New York City,
it's "The Tonight Show
starring Jimmy Fallon"!
-♪ Hey, hey hey, hey ♪
-Tonight, join Jimmy
and his guests --
Ewan McGregor,
Annie Murphy,
comedian Jackie Fabulous,
and featuring
the legendary Roots crew.
-♪ 1660 ♪
-And now, here he is,
Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hey, hey hey, hey ♪
-Hey, thank you!
Thank you very much!
Hello!
Hi!
Oh, come on, now.
Hey, I appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
That's what I'm talking about.
Hey.
-Oh, my goodness!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Doesn't that feel good?
That feels great.
Welcome, everybody.
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate it.
Guys, some big movie news.
Today, "Top Gun: Maverick"
was released in theaters
across the country.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
It is finally out
after a three-year delay.
[ Laughter ]
Yep. When they heard,
even Spirit Airlines was like,
"Damn, respect."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the movie is incredible.
And of course, Tom Cruise,
once again,
does all of his own stunts.
Meanwhile, every flight
attendant who's dealt with
a drunk passenger is like,
"No big deal, so do we."
[ Laughter ]
I've seen the movie,
and the action is incredible.
The last time I felt that tense
at a movie theater,
it was 'cause someone coughed.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, "Top Gun: Maverick"
just opened,
and everyone's super pumped.
Of course, a lot of fans
have been quoting
the classic "Top Gun" line
"I feel the need --
the need for speed."
Yep. But some people,
especially in Washington,
didn't quite
get the quote right.
And it's interesting.
I'll just show you what I mean.
Some examples.
For instance,
Senator Rand Paul said...
[ Laughter ]
Next up,
Senator Roger Marshall said...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Up next,
Senator James Lankford said...
[ Laughter ]
Next up,
Senator Ron Wyden said...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. Okay.
-Next up,
Senator Tammy Baldwin said...
[ Laughter ]
Up next,
Senator Bob Menendez said...
-What did he say?
[ Laughter ]
-What does that mean?
-Up next,
Senator Jon Tester said...
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
Are we gonna do all 50 Senators?
-Next up,
Senator Ben Sasse said...
[ Laughter ]
And finally, 88-year-old
Senator Chuck Grassley said...
There you go.
A lot of misquotes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A lot of misquotes there.
A lot of misquotes.
-Wow!
-Guys, it was a big day here
at NBC 'cause tonight
was the series finale
of "This Is Us."
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And as expected,
it was pretty emotional.
Actually, check out this ad
that ran towards the end.
Look at this.
-When you need to refuel after a
workout, you drink Gatorade.
And when you need to recover
without sugar, you drink G Zero.
And when you need to rehydrate
after you bawl your eyes out
watching the series finale
of "This Is Us,"
you drink Gatorade Chardonnay --
The only wine from Gatorade
for "This Is Us" fans.
Filled with boozy electrolytes
that'll help you fuel up
after breaking down.
Gatorade Chardonnay.
[ Voice breaking ]
Please don't leave us, Pearsons!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
We miss you!
[ Applause ]
Did you guys see this?
Prince William's 40th birthday
is next month.
And to celebrate,
he's being featured
on a £5 commemorative coin.
Here it is.
Eh?
And this is cool.
The back of the coin
has his bald spot.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, guys, listen to this.
I heard that since so many
car makers have left Russia,
Moscow is restarting
a Soviet-era car brand,
called Moskvitch.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause everyone's leaving.
Yeah, yeah.
So now, Moskvitch --
they're making --
we actually have a sneak peek
at Moskvitch's first commercial.
-Oh.
-Take a look at this.
-[ Russian accent ]
Ever dreamed of hitting speeds
over 18 miles per hour?
You deserve a car that rides
so smooth, you'll feel like
you're in front seat of cabbage
car pulled by sick donkey.
[ Donkey brays ]
Hi, I'm Boris Sokolov,
CEO of Moskvitch,
biggest automobile manufacturer
in Russia.
And we have car that comes
in many beautiful colors,
like gray and muted gray.
And one that has
many state-of-the-art features,
like steering wheel.
-Most models do not contain
steering wheel.
-Put the key in the ignition
and listen to that baby purr.
[ Trilling ]
[ Metal clanking, rattling ]
We're Moskvitch,
by Moskvitch.
Round tires coming soon.
-Oh, interesting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, get this.
I read that the CEO of Nokia
said that 6G
will be here by 2030.
Yep.
That was the news of the future
brought to you
by a company of the past.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is something
you don't see every day.
Deputies in Ohio encountered
an Amish man
who is suspected
of being under the influence
while operating
a horse and buggy.
[ Laughter ]
Watch this.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-"He'll get home."
[ Laughs ]
That's basically the Amish
version of self-driving Tesla.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, guys, it's Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you five
different tweets, and we're all
gonna vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
Yep.
Look at the confusion there.
There you go. Perfect.
You can vote for all of
these tweets, by the way,
if you like them. We'll see.
You'll see the voting polls
when they come in.
You can vote for none of them
if you feel like
voting for none of them,
if you go like, "I don't even
want to play this, Jimmy.
Just do the work
and just leave me alone."
I understand. You're gonna
see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers, too.
-Got 'em.
-Now, have you ever
gotten close on this?
Like, have you chosen
the right one?
-Yeah.
I always choose the right one.
I've never gotten it wrong.
Have a perfect score
so far on "WeTweet."
-Alright. Let me see.
Here you go.
So, anyways, we're gonna vote.
Whichever one you like,
we're gonna tweet it out.
And then you at home
can like it and WeTweet it.
-Hm!
-It's a shared experience.
Thank you very much.
Don't vote on that joke,
by the way, please.
That one's a -- That one's
already making the show.
That's guaranteed.
Alright. This first tweet is...
-No. No.
♪♪
-You can't say no.
-Fro no.
-That's what the clickers
are for.
-Okay.
-They're not voice-activated.
-No!
-The votes are in.
Let's see the results here.
Oh, my God.
Come on!
-Come on, man!
No! No!
-Alright.
If you're in a hurry, you go,
"Hey, I need some fro yo,"
but if you're
in less of a hurry --
-You go,
"I need some frozen yo."
-Yeah.
-No, we got it.
-Yeah, I know you did.
This next one is --
There's this one.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
-Gosh.
-I don't know, man. Maybe --
I feel like I ejected.
[ Laughter ]
I mean...
I'm not feeling good
about this one, either.
But let's see the results
on this one there.
Alright. Hey.
-Oh. Wow.
[ Applause ]
-Okay.
So far, that's in the lead.
-131.
-We got three more.
So, if you really liked
that one,
you know,
don't play the game anymore.
Yeah.
-Just lock that one in.
-I feel like
that's going to be top.
-Yeah.
-Alright. The next one is...
[ Laughter ]
[ Jimmy laughing ]
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
"Um, hi. I thought
we said 9:00? What's up?"
-I like that.
-Yeah, that's pretty good.
Alright.
Let's see the results.
[ Drum roll ]
Whoa! Whoa!
-That's like a dead heat!
Wow!
-Whoo, whoop!
-That was a polarizer.
-Boop! Yeah, it was cool!
-Beeyoop!
-Yeah.
-Alright. Oh, I like this one.
Next up says...
-There you go.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Got the -- got the --
Tariq liked that one.
Got a little giggle.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I'm gonna say 186.
-Alright. You think 186 people?
-Mm-hmm.
-That's almost like
a landslide vote.
-Yeah, landslide.
-Alright.
You think so, too?
-Yep.
-Let's see the results.
[ Drum roll ]
-Whoa!
-Off by two!
-Fantastic bid!
-Wow!
-That's probably gonna be --
I feel like that's
gonna be the one right there.
-Well, maybe. Who knows?
This one might top it.
-No, I know.
That one's not gonna top it.
But here's the last one
just so you have it.
-Okay. Alright.
-We can change it.
It's up to you guys. You decide.
This is real-time. Here we go.
Uh, it says...
That's what the mug says.
-Do you think
you'd drink it like this?
Do you turn it as you drink it?
So it's like --
So you can read it.
-'Cause there's so many words
on the mug.
-Yeah, so you read it as you go.
-Yeah.
Or you get a larger --
-Or a huge mug.
-Mug, yeah.
Like a "Friends" novelty...
-Oh, yeah.
Like a comically large mug.
-Yeah, like a "Talk Soup"...
-Oh, yeah!
-Oh, my God.
-I forgot if I voted or not.
Anyway. It doesn't matter.
It's gonna be the zoo one
either way.
Let's see the results.
[ Drum roll ]
Ah! I was right! There you go.
The winner is number four.
It is the zoo one, right there.
[ Bell dinging,
cheers and applause ]
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like.
Give it a wetweet and enjoy.